hey guys it is the 29th of April my name
is Jess McDonald and you're watching
games but news also there are days on my
shed tears dear ears first up Microsoft
are promising that their TV push won't
impact on the game a first approach to
xbox one Xbox exact Jordan Levin has
said that it's probably worth saying
that none of the activity we're pursuing
is coming at the expense of any of the
investment that's been made in the
platform overall all gaming overall
exact Nancy Tellem has explained that
the TV efforts are basically to keep
users entertained between big game
launches let me know if you're keen for
xbox live TV or not next up all the
juicy content from the watchdog season
pass has been unveiled and here's what
you can expect within the new single
player content players will embody the
role of t-bone who is apparently a
brilliant but eccentric hacker who lives
by his own rules and not the rapper by
the same name as if anybody's really
that surprised as a rapper named t-bone
extra content includes a mode called
digital trip which will have you hunting
cyborgs for some totally unknown reason
and you'll get a bunch of other weapons
outfits missions and whatnot driveclub
has had another delay but it's also got
a new director so I'll leave you to be
excited disappointed or apathetic
accordingly evolution studios dev porous
jansky who was previously game director
on motorstorm RC will be heading up the
game which is now set to debut on
october seven that may be a somewhat
familiar date since it's the same day as
the releases of dragon age inquisition
middle-earth shadow of mordor and alien
isolation this has now pushed the game
back almost a full year but Playstations
Shuhei Yoshida is promising that the
innovative socially connected racing
game is totally worth it and finally
let's revisit one of our favorite
stories from the last 224 days when on
earth is GTA 5 coming to PC the
change.org petition to bring the game
across from consoles now has over 700
thousand signatures and the time between
GTA 5 console release and hypothetical
pc release is now even longer than it
took the GTA 4 to make its way over a
number of rumors are suggesting that
will get a pc version sometime this year
but none of these reports have been
confirmed just yet do you believe in GTA
5 coming to pc and would you buy it on
the platform you can let me know your
thoughts in that commenting section down
below or on my twitter where I'm at just
McDonald those are all the things I want
to tell you about today now please
excuse me while I go create multiple
aliases to sign that GTA 5 on PC
petition I'll see you tomorrow